well there are the french president
emmanuel
macron reacting to a large rise in
coronavirus cases
reacting at last uh some saying to a
rise in coronavirus cases
in france thereby announcing new
lockdown measures
and ask for the reasons why one
statistic sticks out that
president macron mentioned there that in
french intensive care
units 44 of those in those crowded units
are now under the age of 65 and
president macron announcing their as i
say new lockdown measures uh
an extension of curfew measures from 7
p.m from this saturday
uh closing of schools and of
non-essential
retail uh the french president saying
the sacrifice is necessary but
also mentioning ending there on an
optimistic note saying the
vaccination program in france's is
gathering pace and he has an
intention of making sure that all people
over the age of 18 in france will be
vaccinated by the end of the summer he
didn't specify a
particular month on that well let's get
reaction from our europe correspondent
listening into all that
adam parsons joins me now so um the
french president making it very clear
there emmanuel macron
that uh he's acting reluctantly but
acted he has and this is
changing what has up to this point being
a series of kind of
piecemeal regional lockdowns and
measures he's gone for
for the whole nation now
this really was a classic bit of a
manuel
macron rhetoric it was
a speech laced with uh with care
with politics and also with
a little grain of self-aggrandizement
because the speech was all
largely the subtext what haven't we i
done really well look at germany look at
italy look at britain giving us this
troublesome variant
we've tried our best to keep schools
open we've done everything we can for ye
but now we've got to a point where we
have to uh we have to pull some more
triggers and pull them they have
it's been criticism interestingly that
the restrictions they brought in
a couple of weeks ago haven't really
done very much now
he has brought out the big bazooka which
is to say that these restrictions will
apply across the whole country
uh a 7 p.m curfew telling people to work
from home
closing non-essential shots now you
don't have to have paperwork to walk
around
on the street certainly not at the
moment but these are
pretty much the pillars of the lockdown
of last year
and i think one of the things that maybe
has pushed him towards this
is a gathering sense amongst the general
public in france
that they need to do this a poll today
said 54 of people
wanted a strict national
lockdown faced with what they see as
these very
rapid rises in hospitalizations uh in
and in the use of intensive care and a
very interesting statistic
uh he said there was the sheer number of
people 44
of patients in intensive care now aged
below 65 and i think you have to also
say
that the vaccine rollout for all of mr
macron's a very optimistic pronouncement
has up to this point been not successful
interesting he did say vaccine centers
have to be open
uh seven days a week well we visited one
of the biggest planned ones today
and it won't be it'll be open uh six
days a week
so this an important speech for him an
important moment for france
and it came after the end of a day of
soul
searching about where france should go
next